err it's uh it's it's I couldn't believe
it like the first the first few minutes
of the demo my I can't believe I'm
actually seeing this i'm not like i'm
not even a huge team eco fan it was more
the mystique of the game a guy yeah this
legends like a unicorn exists yeah it's
real and it's happening and it's it's
coming later than we thought it was
gonna come I thought it was gonna talk
about it would come this fall I thought
that was gonna actually be there big
fall game but here it is yeah I mean it
that would that was the thing is that
it's this weird surprise we you know
there's this hashtag going around the
internet it's trending worldwide every
day called Colin was right because
you've been knocking III predictions in
video game predictions out of the park
for so long your prediction here was
that last garden would finally be
revealed it would finally happen and it
would come out this fall to fill the
vacuum of Sony first party awesome
titles we have for the PlayStation 4
indeed and I also thought that with the
last guardians mystique and also that it
has it has a black eye as multiple guys
if that bird creature had more than two
black eyes they'd all be black because
because that makes any sense yeah if it
because have two black guys already it
would have two black eyes right now what
I was saying was infant had three or
four eyes they'd all be black so if this
was a spider type creature right exactly
Blackjacks that's a better way to put it
hey uh because I feel like you know they
revealed the game and then she's never
came out I mean the game the game's
development cycle is approaching eight
or nine years if not more so because it
was revealed in 2009 but it was in
development along before that remember
shadow of the colossus team egos last
came out 2005 so assuming they even took
a year off the game's development start
in 2006 you think do you think last
guardians gonna get out after uncharted
4 so that the entire uncharted saga has
happened in the time it took between I
hope so cuz I shadow I hope so cuz that
would be awesome that would be the but
or a possible I was always so what I
brought the black eyes for a reason
because i feel like if they're gonna
rear aveal the game was obvious it was
real yeah they they have nothing now to
gain by showing any more of it and i
would i was shocked that they weren't
like it's here's the date and a guy over
whatever and because you know pooja to
tell you now come on 26 teens like yeah
we've been here before yeah but they
certainly wouldn't do this again if they
weren't confident the game was coming
out and rumor out of japan for multiple
sources and is that uh you know mark
cerny himself has taken over the team
he's over there and his fan is the
finisher now my god dammit i made the
playstation 4 work I can make this game
work and he's obviously I mean we've
more well known to a younger generation
or a less experienced in gaming
generation as the architect of the ps4
which he is but I mean the man insomniac
and naughty dog he had his hands all
over those early game so he has a lot of
game development I'm and he didn't act
which no one liked but now but you know
the other crazy thing was that you know
you way too slow for me do you wait oh
who is the visionary at Tamiko doesn't
work at Sony anymore and everyone
assumed was fired yeah was featured
prominently in the trailer and then
shown in the crowd kind of burying the
hatchet symbolically anyway because
there was a lot of rumors about how you
know he was on bed or presumably
assignment rumors it's just conjecture
that surely he was fired sure surely you
don't take this long to make a game it's
weird too because do you think it's just
that he's that all that kerfuffle with
him and Sony had happened so long ago
now that it was able to come full circle
and be fine cuz like right now we're
kind of I feel like we're living that
again with Konami and kajima right like
so now is it but it took so long a
gesture just stated for so long but now
everything's okay yeah it could be I
might my instinct is that you know they
don't want to have any bad blood at
least visibly sheriff if I was Sony I'd
be infuriated I would have canceled this
game already but they probably had dumps
they had dumped so much money on it and
it's such a big deal it's a big deal i
mean you know I and I feel for you wait
in a way I feel for his team when you
make a game like eco tea-making in my
shadow the classes I think both those
games frankly are overrated but they're
considered classics they're considered
absolute classics and a lot of people
think shadow the glasses is the best
game of all time when you're following
up a game like that there is an immense
amount of pressure to deliver and he
probably wasn't pleased with the game on
ps3 and and and clearly they scrapped in
a rebuilt it is I don't know if I'm
crazy or not but this doesn't look like
what we saw oh god no there's no I think
at that point there's no way they're
just uprising the ps3 version right this
game looks beautiful I did period I
thought it looked really good camera
looks a little wonky here for the break
even for the person that's playing which
is funny as hell yeah but they're trying
to that dev stuff where they slowly
spinning or whatever maybe they're not
maybe it's just that it's still that
early in this game that's been going on
ever how is that possible I still want
to know the story behind it though
that's more interesting oh my god I
can't wait to hear that ladies and
gentlemen you'll be sure to hear more of
that and more cool stories right here on
all of GameSpot cross kind of funnies
III coverage
you